so it sounds like you have a a good
relationship with cops these days but i
assume it wasn't always that way was
there kind of a switch where you started
seeing them as as friends or as people
and not as like your enemy or as the
people who were locking you up you know
and you know what let me just there
could be 30 of us standing on the street
and cops would roll up in every hey you
come here what come on pick one of these
suckers but i just had the face that
said i did something wrong you know
and so you know yeah i had a bad
relationship with them and then here
it's like
if you're not doing nothing wrong
they don't give a [ __ ] about you know
what i mean it's like yeah well they're
always picking now they ain't gonna stop
me if i don't do anything wrong hey
what's up i was doing 80 miles an hour
on the diamond lane i was checking i got
a 65 buick riviera right and i'm jam wow
on the diamond lane and i'm by myself
i rolled
cop rolls up behind me man god damn
highway patrol
stop me god
trail what the [ __ ] you got in this
thing
because we were doing buddy i said man i
started telling him he was a car buff
and
stay off the diamond lane let me go
there you go
yeah i noticed as soon as i got eight
years sober and as soon as i got sober
like i stopped hating cops and i was
like well because i've got it i've got
it i'm not getting in trouble anymore
you know what that's the whole deal it's
like you know i've been i mean i've been
stopped and hey what's up
give an autographed picture or whatever
i uh we feed him we just we just came
down yesterday oh from uh um palmdale we
did a big fundraiser for
the police the sheriff and police up
there
for their all the kids in trouble up
there so
you know they call me for everything you
know you know and me and they're say
kids and yeah i'm there can i just tell
you how [ __ ] up my new tour is it's
completely multimedia legitimately
x-rated there's legal waivers all over
the venue because i'm actually worried
about getting sued and i don't give a
[ __ ] man because it's gnarly and it's
all the stuff i wasn't allowed to do on
jackass so get to my [ __ ] website
stevo.com and get your tickets man
especially with this movie coming out
dude they're all gonna sell dude so
hurry up while you can get seats